Working adults spend most of their time at work.
More time than with family.
More time than watching TV.
Even more time than they spend eating and sleeping.
So, it's no surprise that working in an environment where health and safety are a priority...
...is one of the most important ways for people to stay healthy and happy.
Worksite wellness is a people-centered approach to doing business...
...by creating a work environment that promotes safety, physical activity,...
...healthy habits and overall well-being,...
...companies can benefit from higher employee satisfaction,...
...increased loyalty, improved productivity, fewer injuries and lower healthcare cost.
It's not just good business; it's good business strategy.
Building a worksite wellness program doesn't have to be overwhelming or expensive...
...and you may be doing things right now that count:...
...things like swapping out junk food and sugary sodas for healthy snacks,...
...encouraging physical activity during the day,...
...designating your workplace as a smoke-free environment...
...or posting safety notifications in common areas.
These and other simple strategies can be the basis...
...of a good worksite wellness program.
Health links can help get your worksite wellness program off the ground...
...and turn it into a competitive advantage.
You can get certified, get supported, get funded...
...and even get connected to other like-minded small businesses in Colorado...
...who know that a healthy business is good business.
So, get started today.
Go to HealthLinksColorado.org and bring wellness to work.